What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Jacob
Batalon who plays Ned Leeds.
This is a huge film.
Where do we start
with Ned in this one?
Oh my goodness.
Ned is reeling, you know?
His best friend's identity just
has been revealed to the world.
So he is just like,
what does he do next?
What are the folks up to now?
Like we're planning what to do.
It's crazy.
Does Ned to get on
the action on this one?
Oh my goodness, look
you wouldn't believe.
Ned and MJ are killing it.
Yes.
So what was it like working
with Benedict Cumberbatch?
I mean, unbelievable.
He's like so professional
but also such
a funny, amazing human being.
And everyone on the
cast has been amazing.
Like every legend that's been
on has been just amazing.
So we know Ned's arc
throughout these films,
but what has been your
journey through this?
I feel like--
I mean, I've accomplished
everything that I've
wanted to accomplish with Ned.
I feel like he's definitely
become the guy in the chair
to like in the action.
So I think in that way
he's had a great time.
So, yeah.
If you can have any
Spider-man gadget in real life,
what would you choose?
Probably the web
wings so I can fly.
That's awesome, Jacob.
Thank you so much.
Enjoy the movie.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]